congratulations Luke oh man thank you
this is getting to be old habit man this
is wild isn't it oh Lord I would like to
see if you could distinguish between I
what I feel are two of the biggest
Awards the Entertainer which has become
the kind of the showman award if you
will sure and then the album is all
about your Artistry so which one which
one do you perceive to be the one that
is really who you are right now because
it seems like you're doing it all in one
big swoop man I I think it's hard to
distinguish really for me um you know
obviously Entertainer is so huge um for
everything that we do all the time that
we spin away from home and and it feels
like such a huge award for me and my my
team and everybody on the road with me
that spends all this time away to make
sure that we do the best we can and then
the album is everybody that I write
songs with all the studio musicians all
the time that I've spent in there I mean
I spent two years making that record of
my life painstaking years and um
it's never it's never ever good enough
the album can never ever be good enough
but eventually it has to get turned in
and so to be recognized for that it just
means the world to me and my team and my
family and I just couldn't be more
thankful I honestly Blown Away by
tonight
hey how are you hey
the energy
so much energy in your shows anyway how
much more energy does Entertainer number
two give you when you step on the stage
again it's really really hard to believe
honestly and um I I just you know I had
a show a few weeks back and and I went
out there and you know everybody has
tough days at work whether you do what I
do or or you're in here tonight you know
you have things outside of work that
affect how you do at your job and I had
a rough night a few weeks ago and um I
remember coming off stage and closing
the green room for a half an hour
sitting there by myself and taking a lot
of stock of why I do what I do and I
never moved to this town to not have fun
I moved here to love what I do and uh
man I have never loved it more than I do
tonight than I do every night when I
step out on that stage even when I have
a rough night it is uh I'm truly truly
blessed and uh I have a great team and a
great family to thank for that
hi Luke congratulations thank you so
much
um you seem to be the epitome of to them
to Those whom much is given much is
expected sure
um I have made the joke that I don't
know if Luke knows but he's already the
nicest guy ever and has has earned all
of our respect but we're continually
seeing all of these stories and little
moments where you're touching people's
lives and impacting people's lives and
can you just talk about
that thing within you that causes you to
just show such love and compassion and
generosity to so many of your fans and
just people in general yeah just you
know I truly believe when I step out
there every night you know uh coming
back to the other night I I was sitting
in the in the Green Room by myself and I
remember thinking it's like okay you've
You've Won Entertainer you've done this
you've done that like you've checked so
many boxes and what is the thing that
keeps you coming back and there was a
little girl in the audience and she said
were you saying even though I'm leaving
for my daddy in heaven and I remember
reading that sign and being a dad now
myself
um
and just going this is why I step out
here it's not for me it's not for the
money it's not for the awards it's for
the people that spend their hard earned
money to come and spend maybe the only
Saturday night they go out for the whole
year to come and see me and it's not
something that comes you know easy to
afford you know it's uh you know it
could be a 50 ticket for three or four
people in a hotel rooms and babysitters
and gas and or flights or whatever it
may be and I never want that to be
forgotten because without everybody
that's in the audience there is no show
it doesn't matter how cool I think I am
or how good the songs are when
Entertainer of the Year if nobody shows
up then the show doesn't matter and I
think that that is something that I
always try to remember and I've always
been really thankful for people spending
their time with with me and my my band
double congrats thank you is there a
great life lesson that you can share
maybe that was passed along to you or
something that you've learned along the
way
yeah you know
um I I talked I remember last year when
I won
um
a bunch of a bunch of people reached out
to me after after winning Entertainer
last year and uh they said hey man you
just enjoy tonight
um you know it may never happen again
and and it's the the Pinnacle of of
success that you can have in this
business and um I'm not gonna lie to you
I was so nervous tonight about it just
going I I was doing some some interviews
on Monday I was doing radio row and and
people were asking me about it and I
remember having this somber thought of
like well man this could be the last two
days that I'm the Entertainer of the
Year ever like I may never win this
again and so really it's just being
present in the moment that you're in now
I mean my wife is here our son is at
home and like my parents you know are
are still around and just being thankful
for the things that I have right now and
enjoying the moment that I'm in and not
looking forward and not dwelling on
things that are in the past so really
just being present I get to live my
dream every day with people that I love
living it with so I'm just trying to be
as thankful for that every day as I can